550 millionen euro diese summe zahlt der
staat jedes jahr an die beiden kirchen
in deutschland
und nein hier geht es nicht um die
kirchensteuer fast jeder zahlt an dieser
summe mit margarete bußmann aktivisten
der bewegung wir sind kirche fordert
deshalb nimmt dieses geld und helft den
schwächsten
wir denken da an obdachlose an
alleinerziehende die einfach durch
soziale netz fallen
der staat hat sich aber es war die
halskrause verschuldet um die wirtschaft
am laufen zu halten und alle können
nicht von den segnungen des staates
partizipieren und die katholische kirche
die in einer riesen
glaubwürdigkeitskrise steckt die würde
damit ein zeichen von solidarität setzen
aber warum zahlt der staat überhaupt
diese summe jedes jahr an die kirchen
ihren ursprung haben die sogenannten
staatsleistungen in der zeit von
napoleon im reichste mutations haupt
schluss von 1803 nach gebiets verlusten
an frankreich schnappten sich die
deutschen fürsten kirchlicher güter die
klöster und ländereien
dafür bekommen die kirchen seither
staatliche entschädigung über die sie
frei verfügen können
insofern wäre es möglich dass man den
betrag den man als staatsleistungen
bekommt dass die kirchen den einsätzen
für karitative zwecke
aber sagt die katholische kirche für
diese karitative zwecke wird das geld
doch längst auch genutzt
das ist eine realistische vorhaben wir
sind kirche denn die stars leistungen
die die bistümer jedes jahr bekommen
gehen automatisch in die haushalte der
bistümer und mit den aussagen der bist
nur wird eine menge gutes getan in
millionenhöhe bis zum abend teilweise
fonds aufgelegt gerade jetzt der korona
krise also was stars leistung ist ist in
haushalten drin und damit auch in der
korona krise mit involviert trotz dieser
milliarden kirchen haushalte sind die
meisten corona soforthilfen deutlich
kleiner
hier mal ein auszug das bistum hamburg
etwa gibt 100.000 euro für mütter in not
frei das bistum münster 45.000 für
studierende
das bistum münchen 20.000 euro für
mahlzeiten für bedürftige senioren in
den evangelischen landeskirchen sieht es
ähnlich aus
72.000 euro gibt die landeskirche in
oldenburg für lebensmittelgutscheine
frei bremen gibt 5000 euro für
wohnungslose in stuttgart hat die
evangelische landeskirche einen notfonds
eingerichtet und spendet zusätzlich
200.000 euro
dazu kommen in der tat noch die
kirchlichen hilfs und missionswerke die
mit mehreren millionen euro fonds helfen
aber das kommt trotzdem nicht an die
höhe der staatsleistungen ran
viele bistümer und landeskirchen sagen
sie fürchten selbst bald kirchensteuer
einbußen und die kollekte fehlt deshalb
aber echtes vermögen oder rücklagen
anfassen
das tun die kirche mir auch in diesen
zeiten nicht
[Musik]